[Musica]
a quanti di voi è capitato di arrivare
tardi in aeroporto perdere un volo e
prendersela con la persona seduta al
check in a quanti di voi è capitato di
avere uno gagliano hanno troppo grande o
troppo pesante e di discutere per
cercare di portarlo a bordo pur sapendo
di essere nel torto a quanti di voi è
capitato di pensare ma perché non mi
lascio passare qualche chilo in più
cosa le costa non se ne accorge nessuno
sa quanti di voi è capitato di pensare
che sfortuna sono capitato dall'hostess
più lenta pignola arrabbiata frustrata
buon pomeriggio a tutti io mi chiamo
ambra garavaglia di mestiere faccio la
hostess di terra
so che in questo momento la metà di voi
stia pensando a quell'antipatica che mi
toglie sempre i bagagli a mano
vorrei dire di no e invece si sono
proprio quella l'altra metà sta pensando
quanto debba essere bello viaggiare per
il mondo vedere posti nuovi
no quella e lotte di volo io sono
hostess di terra quindi lavoro al terra
sempre in aeroporto proprio alla persona
che difesa al bagaglio a mano e 99 per
cento delle volte ve lo toglie perché
non è in regola ma non solo controllo i
vostri biglietti verifico cambiate tutti
i documenti in regola per la vostra
destinazione imbarco e bagagli e vi
faccio salire sull'aereo
detto così sembra tutto facilissimo
eppure vi assicuro che il nostro
mestiere non è così semplice
innanzitutto è fisicamente faticoso per
via dei turni per esempio può succedere
che un giorno inizia alle 4 del mattino
il giorno dopo alle 9 quello dopo ancora
alle 6 iniziare a lavorare alle 4 del
mattino per me che abito abbastanza
vicino all'aeroporto
vuol dire puntare la sveglia alle 230
svegliarsi alle 2 e 30 del mattino se
così si può chiamare in inverno
soprattutto è l'esperienza più vicina al
pre morte che io abbia mai vissuto
e un lavoro anche fisicamente faticoso
perché dobbiamo camminare
camminiamo tantissimo non so se qualcuno
di voi sia stato a malpensa recentemente
negli ultimi 34 anni è diventato un
aeroporto immenso per farvi capire
quando sono rientrata dalla maternità ho
trovato un aeroporto completamente
rinnovato ma ingigantito come primo
insegnamento mi è stato dato l'imbarco
di un volo nell'area nuova il satellite
ci ho impiegato 20 minuti per arrivare
una volta terminato l'imbarco ci ho
messo dieci minuti per capire dove
dovessi andare esattamente mi sono persa
circa 78 volte e ho camminato talmente
tanto che a un certo punto il mio
telefono si è congratulato per aver
raggiunto l'obiettivo giornaliero di
10.000 pasti
tutto questo dopo due ore di lavoro
abbiamo anche tante responsabilità
dobbiamo appunto controllare che abbiate
tutta la documentazione necessaria per
la vostra destinazione ad esempio i
visti le lettere d'invito la validità
minima del passaporto
il biglietto di ritorno e se sbagliamo
la compagnia aerea prende una multa così
come la società per la quale lavoriamo e
anche noi quando veniamo chiamati perché
si comunichino l'errore passiamo una
decina di minuti non proprio piacevoli
per questo quando ci mettiamo più tempo
per fare un check in
non siamo l'ente o svogliate dobbiamo e
vogliamo essere sicure e no quando ci
dite ma non si preoccupi vado sempre o
si fidi il visto lo faccio all'arrivo
non ci fidiamo
ma la cosa più impegnativa del nostro
lavoro è sicuramente il contatto con il
pubblico
non fraintendetemi io adoro le persone
adoro fare un lavoro del genere non
potrei mai lavorare chiuso in un ufficio
però aver a che fare ogni giorno con
così tante persone può essere a tratti
esasperante
questo succede perché tutte le persone
che mettono piede in aeroporto perdono
improvvisamente il senno non siamo
ancora riusciti a capire per quale
motivo ma chiedono dove sia il bagno
davanti al bagno il bar davanti al bar e
il controllo di sicurezza davanti al
controllo di sicurezza entrare in
aeroporto equivale ad entrare in
un'altra dimensione completamente
sconosciuta una volta una signora mi ha
chiesto come funzionasse l'ascensore
perché sa in aeroporto funziona tutto
diversamente
no in aeroporto l'ascensore funziona
come in tutto il resto d'italia e del
mondo
ve lo assicuro è proprio per risposte
episodi come questi che iniziato a
scrivere su twitter è diventato una
sorta di diario non proprio segreto dove
condividere tutti questi bizzarri
racconti il check in
rappresenta il primo vero il check e
rappresenta il primo vero ostacolo per
chi deve prendere un aereo
normalmente per accettarvi su un volo
c'è sufficiente il documento di identità
però soprattutto chi non è abituato a
viaggiare tende sempre a darci tutti
quanti i fogli che ha stampato a casa
nonostante i nostri basta documento
grazie una volta la signora mi ha
risposto senza io ho fatto tanta fatica
a stampare tutte queste cose le prenda
ok
in realtà vi svelo un segreto quando vi
chiediamo il foglio di prenotazione vuol
dire che non troviamo il vostro nome
nella lista passeggeri quindi non
essendo un buon inizio sempre meglio
evitare che ve lo chiediamo una volta
superato questo ostacolo cioè aver
trovato il vostro nome in lista
arriva un momento critico la scelta del
posto
ho visto coppie scoppiare perché lei
voleva stare seduta avanti per sentire
meno i rumori e lui dietro perché si sa
se l'aereo cadde quelli dietro si
salvano ho visto famiglie e disfarsi
genitori cercare di abbandonare i propri
figli piccoli per potersi sedere in
uscita d'emergenza
assistito a litigi e pc e sono stata
insultata tantissime volte perché non
erano più disponibili posti vicini anche
sui voli di 40 minuti
una volta trovato il vostro nome nella
lista passeggeri scelto il vostro posto
arriva il momento per il quale abbiamo
più discussioni in assoluto il bagaglio
partiamo dal bagaglio da stiva
normalmente a seconda della compagnia
con cui viaggia the della vostra
destinazione della classe in cui viaggia
te possiamo avere franchigie in kg oa
pezzi franchigia kg sono varie possono
essere da 15 20 30 40
così come quelle a pezzi potreste avere
un biglietto da zero bagagli 123
l'unica cosa certa è che almeno un
passeggero a volo cercherà di imbarcare
più di quello che gli spetta
gratuitamente
ho sentito scuse di ogni tipo per non
pagare l'eccedenza bagaglio
[Musica]
se per il bagaglio da stiva litighiamo
con almeno un passeggero a volo se
parliamo di bagaglio a mano il numero
sale vertiginosamente normalmente tutte
le compagnie consentono di trasportare a
bordo un pezzo di bagaglio a mano cm più
cm meno le misure sono le stesse e
alcune compagnie concedono un trasporto
il trasporto di un piccolo secondo pezzo
che può essere una borsa personale o la
borsa del computer
ecco la borsa personale deve essere
piccola non può contenere la metà delle
cose che non sono state nel vostro
bagaglio da stiva e la borsa del
computer deve contenere il computer
facile non può pesare 15 kg una volta un
passeggero al quale fatto notare non
potesse avere lo zaino da otto chili e
il trolley da altrettanti kg perché il
bagaglio fosse uno solo mi ha risposto
infatti lo zaino non è un bagaglio a
mano è un bagaglio da spalla
la scusa più utilizzata per portarsi più
peso più pezzi a bordo è sicuramente ma
l'ho sempre portato non funziona anche
se è vero vi assicuro che non funziona
la seconda scusa più utilizzata è solo
in questo aeroporto fate tutte queste
storie non so perché ma ho come
l'impressione che per questa tipologia
di passeggero tutti gli aeroporti siano
quelli del succede solo qui ovviamente
ci sono anche delle scuse più fantasiose
[Applauso]
a questo punto check in è finalmente
terminata arriva un altro ostacolo il
controllo di sicurezza controllo di
sicurezza non mi riguarda in prima
persona perché non è il mio mestiere
però il passeggero viene assalito dal
terrore dei prodotti che non si possono
portare oltre i controlli sicurezza già
al check in e normalmente ci elenca
tutto quello che è all'interno del loro
bagaglio a mano per sapere se sia
possibile portarlo normalmente comunque
quasi tutti i passeggeri riescono a
superare anche questa fase indenni siamo
arrivati all'area imbarchi finalmente
dare marchi esistono due tipologie di
passeggero quelli che si perdono per
l'aeroporto fanno shopping mangiano ti
costringono a chiamarli 20 volte via
speaker e ad avviare la ricerca bagaglio
perché una volta trovato il loro
bagaglio se possibile cancellarli dal
volo e poi ci sono i passeggeri che
quando arrivi al ghetto sono già in coda
nuovi sistemi e loro ti fissano sistemi
le transenne loro fissano netti cartelli
e loro ti fissano bevi un goccio d'acqua
e no non lo bevi perché loro ti fissano
ti senti in imbarazzo non sono
passeggeri sono avvoltoi i passeggeri
che mi mettono più ansia in assoluto
sono quelli che appena metti un piede
dietro i gate arrivano già a chiedere ma
se ritardo ma da che parte in barca ma a
che ora è esattamente l'imbarco non c'è
ritardo perché altrimenti lo avremmo
pubblicato l'orario di marco è scritto
chiaramente sulla vostra carta d'imbarco
e non lo so da che parte imbarco adesso
decido calma dovete stare calmi
ci siamo la rampa ha dato l'okay i passi
l'equipaggio è pronto ad accogliervi a
bordo il carburante terminato le pulizie
sono finite iniziamo l'annuncio dicendo
che imbarcheremo per primi i passeggeri
che hanno i problemi fisici e le
famiglie con bambini piccoli
ecco l'ultimo momento di agitazione
generale tutti vogliono imbarcarsi per
primi
una volta un signore mi ha detto dovesse
iniziare da lui perché non poteva stare
per troppo tempo in piedi aveva male un
po
un'altra volta un passeggero mi ha detto
doveste invece iniziare da lui perché
era nato nel 1953
non ho ancora capito cosa volesse dire
esattamente però per sicurezza
liberarmene lo ha imbarcato per primo ma
i bambini sono la scusa più utilizzata
in assoluto per potersi imbarcare per
primi i bambini di ogni età
dopo chilometri macinati sveglie
improbabili lipidi sequestrati bagagli a
mano imbarcati la mia giornata di lavoro
finisce qua l'aeroporto è davvero un
posto magico e io sono sicura che semmai
cambierò lavoro avrà sempre un posto
speciale nei miei ricordi
vorrei che fosse così per tutti anche
per chi non ha mai volato e quindi un po
ansioso o per chi vola sempre ed è stufo
fa che non sia semplice ma in fondo
vogliamo tutti la stessa cosa che il
volo parta possibilmente in orario e
qualche intoppo lo si risolva nel
migliore dei modi possibili soprattutto
per voi passeggeri io vi prometto che
sarò sempre gentile comprensiva con voi
voi provate ad esserlo con noi
buon viaggio
[Applauso]